This video was made possible by CuriosityStream.
Sign up for the Nebula bundle deal, on sale
for $15 a year, to get access to two great
streaming sites and help support independent
creators at CuriosityStream.com/Wendover.
COVID-19, a virus orders of magnitude smaller
than a particle of dust, has turned daily
life on earth into something deeply unfamiliar.
In the ten or so months since it first emerged,
the virus has settled at a steady clip of
killing 5,000 people per day, or nearly a
million total, currently.
It has played havoc with the world economy,
plunging the globe into the worst economic
crisis since World War Two.
It has interrupted an era of mounting globalization,
and pushed us into a more insular, nationalistic
state.
The effects of this virus are truly all encompassing
and consistently dreadful, but time has bestowed
upon us a reward for our patience.
We are potentially nearing the beginning of
the end, meaning we could now be at the end
of the middle.
That end of this virus will take far longer
than the beginning—we’re likely far from
halfway through the pandemic in terms of time—but
the slow decline in dreadfulness is potentially
on the horizon.
That’s because a vaccine is coming.
There was previously a period of doubt on
whether an effective vaccine could be developed,
it’s never a sure shot, but all indications
currently suggest, given the unprecedented
extent of scientific effort, that it is indeed
coming.
The only and paramount question is when.
Right now, in September, 2020, all attention
is focused on the late-October, early-November
timeframe.
That’s the earliest possible moment when
any of the frontrunner vaccines, from major
manufacturers including AstraZeneca, Pfizer,
and Moderna, could enter regulatory review.
If all the data confidently point to the vaccine
exhibiting an acceptable level of safety and
effectiveness, it is possible that one of
these will then be granted emergency use authorization
by the American FDA, or its equivalent by
other major national regulators.
It’s worth noting that this is far from
a sure-shot, but experts do say that having
a vaccine in 2020 is a less-than-long-shot
possibility.
However, it is almost certain that you will
not be injected by a COVID-19 vaccine in the
year 2020.
It is possible, but for the average person,
when you actually get a dose of a COVID vaccine
has much less to do with when it’s approved,
and more with how fast it is manufactured
and distributed.
The full effects of the pandemic—health,
social, and economic—will not end until
a critical mass of people are vaccinated.
That means that when we get back to normal
life has much more to do with when the last
person is vaccinated, rather than the first.
This is why some have said that the fast distribution
of a vaccine will be an even greater challenge
than the development itself.
This process, this challenge of getting the
majority of the world's population vaccinated,
can quite legitimately be described as the
most daunting and consequential single logistical
challenge ever.
The stakes have never been higher, but the
challenge has also never been greater.
Let's look at why.
First and foremost, it's a scale problem.
Shipping and administering one vaccine to
one person is not difficult, but shipping
and administering five billion vaccines to
five billion people is.
That’s because there just isn't enough room
in our world's logistics network, as it is
now, to do that.
Making it even tougher, there’s more chance
than not, based on the current leading candidates,
that the first major vaccine to be approved
will require two doses administered 21 or
28 days apart.
That doubles the challenge.
Distributing ten or more billion doses of
a vaccine would be difficult enough in normal
times, but these are far from normal times.
With international travel all but nonexistent—currently
sitting at more than 90% down—passenger
airlines have dramatically cut back their
international route networks.
Now, this is an issue because traditionally,
some 50% of pharmaceuticals are shipped in
the belly-hold of passenger aircraft, rather
than on dedicated freighters, as this can
help get them closer to their final destination
faster.
With limited passenger service, overall cargo
capacity is down about 30%, while cargo demand
is only about 15% down, meaning there is already
a supply crunch.
This has led to existing dedicated freighter
aircraft being used more, additional dedicated
freighters coming into service, but still,
due to constrained supply, a dramatic increase
in shipping costs.
Even already, before the COVID vaccine comes
into the global logistics network, pharmaceutical
manufacturers have had to come up with new
techniques to ship their goods including,
for example, flying their product to where
shipping rates are cheaper and trucking them
to their final destination or charteri ng
private planes.
Of course, the world already experienced a
massive logistics challenge this year with
the distribution of personal protective equipment,
and shippers were able to scale up for that
reasonably successfully, but there’s one
simple reason why it won’t be so easy this
time around: the cold chain.
Vaccines are temperature-sensitive.
Most all of them have to be stored in a highly
precise, climate controlled environment in
order to stay safe and effective.
So, the cold chain is the supply chain suited
to shipping goods that need to be kept cold
or frozen, such as meat, chemicals, and pharmaceuticals.
Of course, the difficulty with the cold chain
is that everything used has to be specialized—the
origin warehouse, the truck, the plane, the
en-route warehouse, and the final destination
each need to have the equipment to keep the
goods at the specified temperature or the
goods have to be shipped in packaging that
keeps them at the specified temperature.
Both options are complicated and complication
compounded by other complication is what makes
a true logistical challenge.
It doesn’t end there, though.
One of the leading vaccine candidates, Pfizer’s
BNT162b2, must be stored and transported at
around -90 °F, or -68 °C. That is far, far
colder than the requirements of most vaccines,
which can ship either at refrigerated temperatures
or a wider range of freezing temperatures.
A thermal requirement such as this is a whole
different ball-game, and it means that they'll
be able to use only a subset of cold chain
infrastructure, which is already a subset
of the overall logistics infrastructure.
Beyond the issue of actually getting such
a vaccine to a distribution site, most hospitals
don't even have facilities to keep a vaccine
at such a temperature, let alone clinics or
pharmacies, meaning that even finding places
that can receive this vaccine is a challenge.
Part of the reason why this obstacle has come
up is that traditionally, vaccines are thoroughly
tested to determine what sort of storage and
shipping conditions they can endure while
still staying safe and effective, but with
the breakneck pace of development for these
COVID-19 vaccines, there likely will not have
been enough time to conduct these tests before
distribution, meaning they'll have to keep
the standards at what's already proven.
So, to reiterate, already, a likely vaccine
will only be able to be shipped through a
subset of a subset of a subset of an already
strained logistics network, to a subset of
sites, and it'll need to happen many billions
of times, but even the solutions to these
challenges present additional challenges.
Pfizer, for example, knowing that the unique
distribution requirements of their vaccine
could limit its commercial success, has developed
a partial solution.
It’s essentially a highly specialized stand-alone
box that can, with the use of dry ice, keep
the vaccine at the required temperature for
up to ten days.
This means that, hypothetically, the vaccine
could be shipped through a more traditional
logistics network, however, this box has highly
specific requirements.
For one, upon arrival, it can only be opened
twice per day, not more than one-minute at
a time, in order to keep the vaccines at the
required temperature.
That means that a distribution site would
need to accurately predict how many doses
they would need in a given day before that
day—if they take out too little, they’d
be slowing the process by not vaccinating
everyone they can, but if they take out too
much, they’d have potentially life-saving
vaccines go to waste at the end of the day.
Also, this box can only carry vaccines in
multiples of a thousand, and keep in mind
that it only keeps cold for ten days.
So, how, for example, do you go about getting
the vaccine to a clinic that can only vaccinate
fifty people in a day—like a rural clinic
in a small town.
Even if shipping was instantaneous, they could
only vaccinate five-hundred people in ten-days,
meaning half their vaccines would go bad.
Pfizer is apparently developing a smaller
temperature-controlled box to solve this problem,
but that means adding a whole other type of
distribution, which increases complexity,
which slows the process down.
In its scenario planning, the American CDC
mapped out a distribution process for if both
Pfizer and Moderna’s vaccines are approved
and, if this happened, the Pfizer vaccine
would be directed to only large distribution
sites that would either have the facilities
for ultra-cold storage, or the capacity to
vaccine enough people that the short shelf-life
of these vaccines wouldn't be an issue.
Then, the Moderna vaccine, which only requires
traditional freezer temperatures, would be
directed to smaller sites with less advanced
facilities.
This would certainly create a scenario in
the US, and likely elsewhere, where the Pfizer
vaccine would be primarily distributed to
people in cities, while the Moderna vaccine
would be the vaccine of choice for rural areas.
Another challenge that needs to be confronted
is the order of operations for distribution.
The Coronavirus affects different people in
different ways.
This means that if we want a vaccine to save
the the most number of lives possible, the
first person in line should be that who is
most susceptible to COVID-19, and the last
person in line should be that who is least
susceptible.
One set of research modeled two scenarios—the
first where, of the first 3 billion doses
available, 50 high-income countries buy up
2 billion of them.
The second was where the first 3 billion doses
were distributed to countries proportionally
based on their population, regardless of wealth.
In this model, twice as many people died overall
with the first scenario—the wealthy countries
first scenario—than the equitable, proportional
approach.
However, for vaccination purposes, it is the
least wealthy countries, arguably those that
need the vaccine most, that are toughest to
distribute to.
Poor countries tend to have limited cold chain
infrastructure, let alone normal logistics
infrastructure, and fragmented, poorly-funded
healthcare systems.
Distributing and administering a complex vaccine
like Pfizer’s will already be tough enough
in the wealthy countries like the United States,
but just imagine how difficult it will be
to get a vaccine from distributor to someone’s
arm in rural Democratic Republic of the Congo,
for example, in ten days, while keeping it
at -90 °F.
How soon a COVID vaccine is administered will
quite directly correlate to how many lives
are saved.
Every day of delay will, with certainty, lead
to more death and despair.
The manufacturers are working as fast as they
can, they are already producing millions of
doses of their vaccines before they’re approved
so they can be distributed as fast as possible,
and regulatory agencies have been preparing
for months for an unprecedentedly fast review
process, so it is now truly down to every
member of the global logistics network to
save lives.
Of course, many of those that will be involved,
especially once we get to wide-scale distribution,
will be companies, not governments or nonprofits,
and for them, this presents a massive business
opportunity—in addition to the positive
public relations potential.
UPS, for example, has built two freezer farms
in Louisville, Kentucky, and Venlo, Netherlands,
near their hubs, which can each hold 48,000
doses and can go down to the temperatures
required for the Pfizer vaccine.
DHL and FedEx too are reportedly massively
upscaling their cold-chain infrastructure
to be able to handle some of the surge in
demand, while other lesser known logistics
companies are too.
Ultimately, though, its tough to find someone
in-the-know who doesn’t admit that shipping
will be a bottleneck.
We already know it’s not going to go perfectly,
so right now, it’s about doing as much work
as possible to make sure the process goes
as well as it can be.
This will come down to making sure that as
much planning work as possible is done now,
before the vaccine is approved, so that distribution
can happen as fast as possible when that does
happen.
Now is the time to figure out how and where
the vaccine will be distributed.
If you are a healthy, relatively young person
thinking selfishly, you should care tremendously
about the distribution process, because you
are at the back of the line.
When you get your shot, when you get to start
letting your guard down, has everything to
do with how fast everyone in front of you
gets theirs, and how fast they get theirs
will also impact how many of them will die.
We know this process will not be perfect,
and it wouldn't be reasonable to ask for perfect
given the complexity of the challenge, but
if we truly put every effort into planning
and preparing for this now, and create a system
that orders people by need, rather than wealth,
we can at least know, at the end of this,
that no lives could have been saved if only
the vaccine got to them faster.
For our collective consciousness, looking
back far in the future, this moment will be
defined not by when we get to go back to concerts
or parties or the gym, but rather by how many
lives we saved when confronting what is hopefully
the greatest global challenge of this generation.
As you’ve heard before, the point of Nebula—the
streaming site that I and other independent
creators founded—is to make a greater variety
of content types possible.
For example, I know many of you were fans
of my and Brian from Real Engineering’s
old podcast, Showmakers, where we interviewed
different educational creators about their
background, story, and process, but the financials
of that show just didn’t work so we stopped
it.
Nebula, however, has made it possible for
us to re-launch it, so we’ve just done exactly
that—Showmakers is now a Nebula original
podcast.
This is in addition to the two Wendover originals
we’ve done already, the Half as Interesting
original, and another Wendover original that
is coming out next month.
Of course, the best way to get access to Nebula
is CuriosityStream’s bundle deal, on sale
now for $15 a year.
With that, you also get access to CuriosityStream
where you could watch, for example, the piece
they made about how the development of the
COVID vaccine works, filmed with the actual
scientists involved.
That’s, of course, in addition to the thousands
of other educational shows and documentaries
they have, and together with Nebula, this
represents, truly, the best deal in streaming.
Sign up today for the bundle deal for just
$15 a year, with current sale pricing, at
CuriosityStream.com/Wendover.